the understanding which is our object
finds itself in just this position that
the inner world has come into being for
it to begin with only as a universal
still unfilled in itself the play of
forces has merely this negative
significance of being in itself nothing
and it's only positive significance that
of being the mediating agency but
outside of the understanding the
connection of the understanding with the
inner world through the mediation is
however its own movement through which
the inner world will fill itself out for
the understanding what is immediate for
the understanding is the play of forces
but what is the true for it is the
simple inner of world the movement of
force is therefore the true likewise
only as something altogether simple we
have seen however that this play of
forces is so constituted that the force
which is solicited by another force is
equally the soliciting force for that
other which only thereby becomes itself
a soliciting force what is present in
this interplay is likewise merely the
immediate alternation or the absolute
interchange of the determinate 'no suits
the soul content of what appears to be
either a universal medium for a negative
unity it ceases immediately on it on its
appearance indeterminate form to be what
it was on appearing by appearing
indeterminate form it solicits the other
side to express itself that is the
latter is now immediately what the first
was supposed to be each of these two
sides the relation of soliciting and the
relation of the oppose determinate
content is on its own account an
absolute reversal and interchange of the
determinant 'no stool asians themselves
are again one and the same and the
difference of form of being the
solicited and the soliciting force is
the same as the difference of content of
being the solicited force as such that
is the passive medium on the one hand in
the soliciting force the active negative
unity or the one on the other in this
way there vanishes completely all
distinction of separate mutually
contrasted forces which were supposed to
be present in this movement for they
rested solely on those distinctions and
the distinction between the forces along
with both
those distinctions likewise collapses
into only one thus there is neither
force nor the act of soliciting or being
solicited nor the determinate nastain
medium and a unity reflected into itself
there is neither something existing
singly by itself nor are there diverse
antitheses on the contrary what there is
in this absolute flux is only difference
as Universal difference or as a
difference into which the many
antitheses have been resolved this
difference as a universal difference is
consequently the simple element in the
play of force itself and what is true in
it it is the law of force
section 148 is going to lead us to a new
term a new concept it's going to bring
in the conception of law and that's
going to assume greater importance in
later paragraphs where you know it's
typical with Hegel just getting it at
the very end of the paragraph and want
to see how we get there but that's where
we're headed so you want to keep that in
mind he begins by sort of bringing us
back to the point where we were with the
understanding and the relationship to
the inner world being mediated through
the middle term the play of forces he
says the understanding which is our
object notice he says the understanding
is our object we're paying close
attention to that now not just to the
inner world not just to the play of
forces we're trying to understand what's
going on with the understanding we are
actually using reason to do that but he
says the understanding which is our
object find itself in this position the
inner world is come into being to begin
with only of the universal as the
unfilled the in itself we've already
been through that we saw that you know
it's got to be filled up with something
appearance is going to be key to that
but what exactly is it filled with we
don't quite know yet so he says the play
of forces has a negative significance of
being in itself nothing and it's only
positive significance of being the
mediating agency so the reason why the
play of forces matters is because it
gets us to this inner world which is the
expression of force itself don't forget
that we have that earlier on right force
in its expression this is force against
its expression it's its externalization
its play it's spread into multiplicity
this is force in itself and we say well
that's what's going on over there so he
says play of forces is actually being
the mediating agency but it's outside of
the others
the understanding is not yet at the
point where it grasps that the play of
forces is within the scope of
consciousness so he says the connection
of the understanding with the inner
world through the mediation is its own
movement it's in the movement of the
understanding through which the inner
world will fill itself out for the
understanding so the the inner world
this over here the inner being of things
which we saw is the supersensible world
which is actually the same thing in a
certain respect as the sensible world
but viewed in a different way by the
understanding than it is by the
sensibility of perception all of that is
happening because understanding has been
seeking what it is missing in all of
this so it says this is its own movement
it's going to fill itself out for the
understanding what is immediate for the
understanding it is the play of forces
that's what we're able to see that's
what we're able to grasp immediately as
unmediated because it's doing the
mediating for us right so he says what
is the true for it is the simple
interest bifurcation that bifurcations
not going to be overcome in this this
passage either and as a matter of fact
this part right here is not where the
interest lies through the rest of this
this paragraph instead what we're really
interested in and that's why I've got so
much written right here is what's going
on with the forces and the play of
forces so we've we've already been
through this when we talk about planned
forces we mean that there's two forces
and they can be understood in terms of
their form you know as soliciting and
solicited there's this reciprocal
relationship there where the soliciting
is dami by this one and that's also done
by this one soliciting it to solicit and
they are differentiated in that way
where you can also understand it in
terms of content in terms of a unity in
terms of a meaning of providing a medium
for each other the the interplay between
mediation
to multiplicity and unity all of that
sort of stuff is on the site of content
and what Hegel is is highlighting here
is that we have differences occurring
between the two forces and that's the
only way that we can is going to sound
kind of funny the differences are the
only ways the only means we have for
telling the difference between one force
and the other their differentiation
takes place by way of these differences
but he's going to point out to us in
this that each time that we look at it
there's a kind of reversal and
interchange of the determinants of what
makes this force this force so is this
force the soliciting force from
considered from the perspective of form
yes it is the soliciting force but it is
also the soliciting force because it is
solicited by the other force to be the
soliciting force and so you know a
difference would be soliciting so it
doesn't retain that difference no it
loses that difference and takes on a new
difference so what does it lead us to he
says this play of forces and then
ultimately leads us to seeing that each
of the two sides is on its own account
an absolute reversal and absolute
shifting back and forth a duality within
itself right but a duality that's
conditioned in relation to the thing
that it's connected with so the one
force is a duality in relation to the
other force which that it takes on what
it's missing so it does that and because
of this there vanishes completely all
distinction of separate mutually
contrasted forces which were supposed to
be present in this movement there is an
interchange there's a reversal going up
so really this force can become this
force why because the only things that
separate them from being each other the
only things that constitutes something
like and identity for each of them is
their differences and their trading
their differences back and forth so that
means that they don't really have some
sort of stable identity except through
the other so he goes on and he says well
what is a what is the outcome of this
what is the upshot of this so he says in
this there vanishes completely any
distinction between them they rested
solely on those distinctions the
distinctions between the forces along
with those distinctions collapses into
only one so there's we started out with
one force and we saw that that force in
its you know it's very nature could be
differentiated into force and expression
force reflected into itself we saw that
the force you know by itself split into
two forces and now we're seeing them and
come together why are they coming back
together because we're realizing that
the differentiation that took place here
is not a stable one based in any sort of
identity so he says thus there is
neither force nor the act of soliciting
or being solicited nor the determinate
nosov being a stable medium and unity
reflected into itself so that's the form
and the content these differences and
the forces themselves collapse into one
but it's not a unity like the the
oneness that we were looking at before
she says there is neither something
existing singly by itself nor their
diverse antitheses or opposition's on
the contrary what there is in this
absolute flux it is only difference as
Universal difference that's all we have
here is difference as such difference
turned into a universal this is a very
interesting turning point isn't it we
have a difference that in a certain
respect doesn't make a difference
because you can put whatever you like
into it and none of it seems to matter
because we've lost any sort of order or
structure or relation when we reduce
everything to Universal difference we
lose any determinist
now we're thinking we're gonna go from
this so he says this difference is
Universal difference is the simple
element in the play of force itself and
what is true in it so the play of forces
just revealed itself to have only a
difference as Universal difference and
here's where he doll is going to as
usual do something a little bit
mind-blowing we don't want to have a
plate of forces what do we have in step
we have the law of force we have this
new term
coming in why would Hagel use this term
law well as we're going to see when we
get to further sections law is something
that brings in some sort of difference
and then makes other differences be it
just be leveled out it applies to
everything or at least it intends to
apply to everything or is intended by
consciousness to apply to everything and
so law for force is this expression of
difference as Universal difference
the absolute flux of appearance becomes
a simple difference through its relation
to the simplicity of the inner world or
of the understanding the inner being is
to begin with only implicitly the
universal but this implicit simple
universal is essentially no less
absolutely Universal difference for it
is the outcome of the flux itself or the
flux is its essence but it is a flux
that is positive in the inner world as
it is in truth and consequently it is
received in that inner world is equally
an absolute Universal difference that is
absolutely at rest and remains self same
in other words negation is an essential
moment of the universal and negation or
a mediation in the universal is
therefore a universal difference this
difference is expressed in the law which
is the stable image of unstable
appearance consequently the super
sensible world is an inert realm of laws
which though beyond the perceived world
for this exhibits law only through in
seson change is equally present in it
and is its direct tranquil image
in Section 149 Hegel is now going to
clarify and spell out the relationship
between law this concept that he's just
introduced at the end of the last
paragraph in terms of force and the
relationship between the super sensible
world in the world of unstable
appearance so how are these connected
well he's going to tell us the absolute
flux of appearance becomes a simple
difference through its relation to the
simplicity of the inner world or the
understanding so we have a contrast here
the flux of appearances is going to come
the constant you know unstable
you know losing its determinations this
is just the realm of difference that's
all right differences differentiation
differences that make a difference
differences that don't make a difference
you know we've gone through that whole
thing but it's only that in relation to
either the understanding or in relation
to the super sensible world and so what
we're starting to see here now is the
relationship between the understanding
and the super sensible world before in
order for the understanding of super
sensible world that connect up we had to
go through the realm of appearance
appearance have this status of being a
mediating factor that's what we were
looking at but now we've got this
conception of law that's going to make
some important differences so he says
the the flux is the essence of the world
of appearance if the outcome of the
flocs meaning this or the fluxes that's
essence but it's a flux that's positive
in the inner world as it is in truth and
consequently received in that inner
world is equally an absolutely universal
difference that is absolutely at rest
and remains self same so we've got going
on here is a simple Universal which is
Universal difference at the same time
right and this is expressed through law
but this is something that even though
when we talk about difference we'd think
that there's some sort of change going
on in there it's one that is unchanging
it's self same not like the world here
and so what this means is that law as
Hegel is going to say is our stable
image or build like a picture right of
the unstable appearances now what does
that mean let's get away from this this
imagistic idea and thank more in terms
of concepts the the understanding works
with those right so when we have a law
the law tells us what is constant what
remains the same in this flux of
appearance and the changes that are
taking place throughout all the
differences bringing the differences
together and in a certain way saying I
don't really care whether you know this
is different or that is different or
that is different I apply across the
board my rule does not take differences
into account it supersedes the
differences in a way right
that's what Universal difference is able
to do it's able to contextualize it and
say difference doesn't matter as much as
we thought that it did law therefore can
be totally stable now Hegel is gonna go
a little bit further and he's gonna
saying we're not just talking about law
we're talking about laws plural in the
supersensible world this tells us what
the supersensible world is actually
supposed to be says it's an inert realm
of laws which though beyond the
perceived world right we've already
talked about how that takes place
it's not as if it's you know totally
alien to the Percy
world we're grasping it through the
perceived world which is our mediation
but it's an inner realm of laws we're
grasping the structure behind the
perceived world says it exhibits law
only through incessant change the
perceived world right we can grasp that
only in how it's happening it's equally
present in it and as its direct tranquil
image so the perceived world and the
world that supersensible
our interview used with each other and
were able to have an intellectual grasp
through the understanding of the world
of unstable appearance in its truth
through grasping the supersensible world
how do we do that
by formulating by grasping by
understanding and perhaps even by
applying these laws
this realm of laws is indeed the truth
for the understanding and that truth has
its content in the law at the same time
however this realm is only the initial
truth for the understanding and does not
fill out the world of appearance in this
the law is present but is not the entire
presence of appearance with every change
a circumstance the law has a different
actuality thus appearance routines for
itself an aspect which is not in the
inner world that his appearance is not
yet truly posited as appearance as a
superseded being for self this defect of
the law must equally be made manifest in
the law itself what seems to be
defective in it is that while it does
contain difference the difference is
universal or indeterminate however
insofar as it is not law in general but
a law it does contain determinate us
consequently there indefinitely many
laws but this plurality is itself rather
a defect for it contradicts the
principle of the understanding for which
as consciousness of the simple inner
world the true is the implicitly
universal unity it must therefore let
the many laws collapse into one law just
as for example the law by which a stone
falls and the law by which the heavenly
bodies moved have been grasped as one
law but when the laws this coincide they
lose their specific character the law
becomes more and more superficial and as
a result what is found it is in fact not
the unity of these specific laws but a
law which leaves out their specific
character just as the one law which
combines in itself the laws of falling
terrestrial bodies and of the motions of
the heavenly bodies in fact expresses
neither law the unification of all laws
in universal attraction expresses no
other content than just the mere notion
of law itself which is posited in that
law in the form of being universal
attraction merely asserts that
everything has a constant difference in
relation to other things the
understanding imagines that in this
unification it is found at universal law
which expresses Universal reality as
such but in fact it has only found the
notion of law itself although in such a
way that what it is saying is that all
reality is in its own self can
formable to law the expression universal
attraction is of great importance
insofar as it is directed against the
thoughtless way in which everything is
pictured as contingent and for which
determinate nassif or m-- of sensuous
independence
so now that we've got this conception of
law everything should be falling into
place and and simple right we've got the
determinist sees that it can all be
brought into one way of looking at them
the understanding loves that sort of
thing because that's what it's been
after the entire time this unconditioned
Universal that Hegel introduced early on
that we try to get to through the play
of force now we're finding that in law
we've got something that perhaps we can
we can wrap our heads around so he says
it's realm of laws is indeed the truth
for the understanding isn't that great
the understanding is finally reached in
the inner world and its laws what it was
it that had been looking for it truth is
its content in the law well it's never
quite so simple and as we go through
section 150 we're gonna see this play
itself I says at the same time this
realm is only in the initial truths for
the understanding and doesn't fill out
the world of appearance why not this is
where the rules of appearance is going
to reassert its rights and it's its
presence against the inner world and the
understanding he says in this the law is
present but is not the entire presence
of appearance with every true change in
circumstances remember the world of
appearance is the shifting flux this
unstable you know thing where the
difference is some you know the attains
and importance and then they disappear
back into the flux so as a law is
applied to that the log is not entirely
a competent compass it does that fill
out the world says it's not the entire
presence with every change of
circumstance the law has a different
actuality well that would make sense
right when you're trying to apply a
general principle which is what a law is
going to be to a variety of different
cases you're gonna have to do some
extension into whatever it is that
you're applying it to that's going to
introduce a kind of dilemma though or
rather a dialectic so he says appearance
retains for itself an aspect which is
not in the inner world otherwise it
wouldn't be
parents right it would be just the inner
world appearance is not truly posited as
appearance as a superseded being for
self which is what the interval does
Hegel then says this defect in the law
must equally be made manifest in the law
itself so he's going to go from this
experience that we have when we're
trying to apply general rules or general
concepts to the shifting realm of
appearance to say there's something
about the very notion of law itself that
introduces this problem Mac it's not
just a matter of application it's in the
nature of law itself so he says what
seems to be defective in it is well it
does contain difference the difference
law in general is universal and
indeterminate difference right so it's
sort of difference in the abstract
difference as a category for good for
thinking or for metaphysics but not
difference as we actually experience it
and as we want to see things play out
when we're trying to understand the
world that were engaged with so he says
insofar as it is not law in general but
any law one a law about stuff then we're
going to run into some issues it does
contain determinate
so think about the the variety of laws
that we could talk about he uses the law
of universal attraction that we get
gravity from we could talk about other
laws as well
we've been think about economic laws and
we're trying to make sense of people's
economic behavior we could talk about
you know Murphy's Law you know there's a
little bit facetious right but you don't
think about how people actually use
Murphy's Law Murphy's Law is that that
Kant joking thing if it can go wrong it
will go wrong right and that's a perfect
example for this because how many
different ways can something go wrong
you know we might say if we want to
continue this facetious example that
there could be a whole bunch of other
sort of sub laws on
like you can't idiot-proof anything
because idiots will always find who hid
round it right that could be a
subcategory of Murphy's Law and now what
we're doing is what Hegel is concerned
with here which is that one law actually
finds itself getting split up into a
plurality of determinate laws and
anytime that we observe some sort of
regularity like this with some
determinate type of beings whether we
think of this in a range of beings can
away like Heidegger Aristotle would or
whether we think about this if in other
ways as well
what we're running into is that amaz we
that make things more determinate the
laws become less general in scope as we
make things more determinant which is
you know something we desire with laws
we lose some of the generality or
universality of the law so it says there
you know insofar as it's not law in
general but a law does contain a
terminus consequently there indefinitely
many laws but this plurality two law is
a defect because what we want especially
because it's the understanding the
understanding is really happy at
arriving at law in general and doesn't
want all these these confusing little
laws it wants them to be brought
together in one unity that will allow us
to unpack the inner world you can see
something like this with the drive to
have a theory of everything Hegel is
staying right here there is an internal
problematic to trying to get a theory of
everything
by way of this conception of law so he
goes on of course he's gonna provide you
with a theory of everything in the book
isn't he but it's gonna go beyond what
he's calling wha here he says this
plurality is a defect it contradicts the
principle of the understanding for which
as consciousness of the simple inner
world the true is implicitly universal
unity so it wants to let the many laws
collapse into one law wants to
bringing them all all these different
laws under one heading so you know it
doesn't work with universal attraction
with gravity you know sir yeah it's to a
certain degree says there's a law in
which a stone falls you know and we
could also think about projectiles and
cannons something that they were really
into in the you know 16 17 18 19 century
trying to plot this sort of stuff out
those are the sub laws are there laws
like that you know with the heavenly
bodies with astronomy yes as a matter of
fact gravity works for both of them you
could even say that there's
gravitational attraction between you
know the camera that I'm looking at and
myself in this chalkboard it's just such
a small level of attraction in relation
to the the massive mass that we're on
top of the earth it doesn't really make
any difference can you roll a bunch of
laws into one lawn it gets more
complicated when we're thinking about
you know social phenomena but we're
gonna try to stay away from that because
Hegel will discuss matters like that
later on in the section on reason let's
just stick with this one here so he says
the many laws collapse into one law so
we use the law by which a stone falls
you know laws for objects here and the
laws by which the heavenly body moves we
roll them into one law but when they
they coincide like that they lose their
specific character he says the law
becomes more and more superficial and as
a result what is found is not the unity
of these specific laws but a law which
leaves out the specific character so it
turns these into things that have washed
their determinate Innis its
approximating to indeterminate
difference right it doesn't really
matter whether you're talking about Mars
and Earth and the Sun or whether you're
talking about this piece of chalk in the
floor they all work the same way
there's a sort of depth to it but also a
kind of superficiality and banality that
comes with these kinds of laws so what's
going on here
says the unification of all laws and
universal attraction expresses no other
content than the mere notion of law
itself notion of law in general the
concept of it and as we get bigger and
bigger and bigger with this trying to
roll everything into one law we end up
losing any sort of determinacy of
content to it
we almost find ourselves in a kind of
vertigo where we've lost any gripping
points so he says the understanding
imagines in this it has found a
universal law which expresses Universal
reality as such but all it's really
found is the notion of law itself in
such a way that what it is saying is all
reality is in its own self all reality
in this world of appearances is subject
to the law right isn't it really the
case well we've lost the determinacy
that this plurality which was rooted in
appearance was supposed to try to
address so he says the expression
universal attraction is of great
importance insofar as its directed
against the thoughtless way in which
everything is pictured as contingent and
for which determinate us as the form of
centrist independence so it's not like
laws are no good but there is an
internal dynamic to law which means that
as they become more and more general
they in a certain way become less and
less applicable to the world of
appearance in a way that gets to the
heart of the appearances what it yields
versus an inner world that's rather
static a world of laws one that may even
be reducible to mathematics it does not
yield us and this is where Hegel is
going to start moving with this a world
of appearance that has been unfolded in
its intelligibility